- [Mark] All right, Garrett.
Garrett, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- I grew up here in the Bay Area.
More on the coast rather
than the Bay area, per say.
A little town called, Half Moon Bay.
- [Mark] Yeah, just
South of San Francisco.
- [Garrett] Yes, it's
in between Santa Cruz
and San Francisco on highway one.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Yes, I did. They
divorced when I was five.
My dad was kind kinda like a rough,
tough hippie, like biker guy.
And my mom was a like, she
worked for Kaiser hospital.
She's the one who kind of,
the breadwinner who was a,
you know, she kept things going.
She was the responsible one.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- You know, I was a little bit, you know,
it was a little bit rough,
definitely a broken home,
but we at same time, we, you
know, I was fortunate to,
I worked on a fishing boat as a deck hand.
I got to do a lot of things
a lot of kids don't get to experience,
I'd say, you know, especially in this day
and age of video games and
computers and what not.
I was able to experience
quite a few things
and treats that just a lot of kids
don't have the opportunity to do.
- [Mark] Did you finish high school?
- I did.
- [Mark] Good for you.
And where'd your life
go after you left home?
- You know, I also got into
the narcotics business,
so just of course I'm
moving to California, so
and the weed industry
blew up and, you know,
I did quite well for some time
but I was young and dumb
and the money that I made
off that, I kinda just had more
fun than saved and put away.
So, you know, I kind of just
it was one big party for a long time.
- [Mark] Did you do jail time?
- Yeah, I've done jail
time. Prison time, yeah.
- [Mark] For drugs?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And so you're
in the Tenderloin now,
how long have you been down here?
- I don't sleep in the Tenderloin
or stay in the Tenderloin.
I try to get in, get out, you know,
it's where there are some
resources that you can, you know,
like a shower, clean up what
not, but it's a pit, so.
- [Mark] Yeah. So where
do you, where do you stay?
- You know, I stay up on Buena Vista Park
up on Haight street.
It's kind of a little
bit out of the crowd,
that way you can actually like, you know,
have some peace when you go to sleep
and you don't worry about
losing your stuff every night
and getting stolen or beat up or whatever.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] A lot of the
crazy stuff happens there.
- Yeah. For sure.
You know, some people you
wonder if they're crazy?
Are they momentarily homeless,
going through a struggle
or like a lot of people seem
like they like it out here.
I'm like okay.
- [Mark] And what, the harder
drug use started for you when?
- Yeah, about 16, 17, you
know, I fit the, once again
I fit the profile.
I got a scoliosis back surgery
when I was 15, 2001 and I got
hooked on pain medication.
And from there it turned
into heroin and heroin
turned into fentanyl.
- [Mark] So in fentanyl is your drug now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're smoking it or?
- I inject and smoke, yeah. Unfortunately.
- [Mark] It's a dangerous drug.
- Yeah, it is. I've known a
lot of people die here, yeah.
Quite a few.
- [Mark] And how are you
supporting yourself now?
- Right now, mainly boosting
and small drug deals here and there, yeah.
- [Mark] You get caught
for it for boosting yet?
- You know, I got caught one time and due
to the COVID right now it's
really hard to go to jail.
Thank God. And so they just
tell you to not come back.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They don't want to hold you.
- Yeah. It's very hard
to go to jail right now.
You have to be gifted
And not to mention to,
San Francisco County alone
it's kind of like a safe haven here,
where as opposed to,
you go to the East Bay,
you go to Alameda or you go
to San Mateo County residing next door.
They're really, prostitution,
drugs, anything like
that here, they tend to look
a blind eye towards, so yeah.
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- I am 34.
- [Mark] 34. Do you have kids?
- I don't.
- [Mark] Been married
or anything like that?
- Never married. I was in , like I said,
I mentioned earlier too, I was
in quite a long relationship
with my previous girlfriend
and that was last year.
I met her in rehab. We were
both clean for quite a few years
and then just relapsed.
She followed along with me, unfortunately.
And then we just, yeah that
relationship went to hell.
That really, that was downer
on me, so that's kinda-
- [Mark] That's what got you relapsed?
- Yeah. That's what got me relapsed
and that's kind of where, you know,
kind of not my excuse me or anything
but that's what led me
to where I'm at now.
- [Mark] Right. It's that
way for a lot of people.
- Yeah, so.
- [Mark] Do you have good friends?
- You know, I do have
good friends, thank God.
I do have good friends and
like they're supporting me
right now, getting back
into rehab and what not.
So, I'm on the way out of
this mess right now, so.
- [Mark] Good for you. That's great.
- Yeah. Definitely on third
base of getting out of here.
- [Mark] What's been the most
painful part of your life
that breakup, or?
- You know, that breakup too.
And I got to say too is
just the at least for me now
as I'm getting older, is
just my cycles I go through.
I do really, really well.
I'm sober, you know, have a good job.
It's a white picket fence,
whatever, have whatever
and then I throw it all away.
Like self-sabotaging and just to come
out here and do this,
it's not fun, you know?
- [Mark] Right.
- And I don't know. So I'm
trying to figure that out.
Why I keep going through that cycle
and what's causing me to do it,
you know, is it a little bit
of everything, society,
what not, or is it a-
- [Mark] Do you feel loved by both
of your parents when you were a kid?
- Yeah, I do.
It took me a long time to realize
that they did the best they
could, you know, as I got older.
I didn't realize that when I was younger,
but yeah, they did.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Weird way of showing
it, but yeah, they did.
- [Mark] Right. And do
you feel like you are able
to love yourself as an adult now?
- I'm getting better.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. It's the learn and practice.
- [Mark] It's a struggle for everybody.
Yeah. I'm getting better though.
- [Mark] And you've been through rehabs
and things like that?
- Yeah, I've been to a lot of rehabs.
- [Mark] How's that been?
How's that experience been for you?
- You know, I have, I
like, I'm not a big Bible
or AA thumper, but I mean,
I could probably quote you
the book back to back,
but you know, if it works.
I take a little bit of everything.
What works and what doesn't and apply it.
And when I do that
I seem to stay sober
and work a good program.
So, I am a testament that if
you want to get clean and sober
there are resources out there that work.
If you want it, takes a little bit
of work on your part, but
you gotta want it, you know.
- [Mark] What emotions
do you deal with most?
Do you go through
depression or anxiety or?
- Anxiety. For sure.
I've always had that,
I was born with over anxiety, you know.
Always self-analyzing myself.
Am I doing this right,
that right, but yeah.
And then I said to (mumbles), but yeah,
and then anger of not
reaching my potential
in life where I'm at, you
know. Kind of like in my prime.
And I'm like, I'm homeless.
- [Mark] Yeah. You look like,
you could be like, you know
on top of the world right now.
- Right. Right.
- [Mark] I found you on the street-
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Early in the morning here.
- Right. Yeah.
- [Mark] Here in the Tenderloin.
- Kind of embarrassing, you
found me like this, but.
- [Mark] The shame a big
part of this for you?
- Yeah it's totally.
- [Mark] I think it's the shame.
Shame is a big part for everybody.
- Yeah. For me, like, I try
not to live like, you know,
fit the part, like this
morning time right now
you kind of caught me, but I was like, Oh.
I tried to not have that.
- [Mark] And what do you do for food?
You go to the feedings and stuff?
- Yeah, I do, not all the time,
but mainly I like to eat healthy
like when I'm sober
and I'll make a real big health food net.
So that it's like mainly kind of difficult
'cause I don't have a kitchen.
I can't like cook, the
kind of food I like.
So like, I'll hit whole
foods, Trader Joe's a lot.
And I have to, you know,
their halfway decent food.
And I have a buddy who works at a, like
it's a mom and pop locally, locally owned
and like organically grown
shop here in the city.
And I'm able to get a lot of like
my health food stuff I like.
- [Mark] Yeah. So you told me in the car
that you're supporting
yourself by boosting.
- Yeah. Mainly in boosting right now, yep.
I have a couple of different
fences, you know, their orders.
- [Mark] The fence is somebody
who'll buy this stuff for drugs.
- Yeah. High end alcohol, you know,
certain makeup's a big one.
Medicine's a big one too, actually.
So, I can make two, $300.
- [Mark] And that'll
support your drug habit?
- Yeah. You know, and I
like to say to you too,
I like to get a motel room.
I just don't like to sleep
on the street, like, you know
have a shower and a kitchen.
So, two, $300 goes quick.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know, it does.
- [Mark] And is your family,
do they know you're out here?
- They do.
They don't know right now,
that it's as bad as it is right now.
They think, you know, I was just
on unemployment this
past year and what not.
They don't know the full extent of it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. I didn't even go back
for Christmas or anything.
'cause I didn't, you know.
They can tell just by
looking at me, you know,
I'm 20, 30 pounds under
weight and bags under my eyes.
Now that they, you know,
they're alcoholic
themselves too, but it just
it wouldn't be pretty.
- [Mark] What have you learned
from all your mistakes?
- I gotta say is, don't
beat yourself up too much.
Just get back up and
you know, keep trying.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Don't give up.
- [Mark] I think believing
in yourself is a big part.
- Absolutely. Totally.
- [Mark] Because it's so
easy to get down on yourself.
- Yeah. As much as you look at your faults
and where you went wrong, you
also, you got to look at well,
your rights and what you have done right
and that you can do it again.
- [Mark] Yeah. Especially if
you're like a perfectionist
or something like that.
- Yeah, I got that a little bit in me too.
- [Mark] You can be so hard on yourself-
- Right.
- [Mark] And that, that
just keeps the cycle
of destruction going, doesn't it?
- Totally.
- And then it's true like,
especially, well I've noticed
if you look at the homeless
population too, it's like,
a lot of it, I don't know
if it's mental health issues
which is a big one.
- [Mark] That's a big one.
- But, I definitely say like
80% of the people are addicted
to some kind of narcotic
or alcohol, whatever it is.
There's a, you know-
- [Mark] 80%? I would think about 99%.
- You're right, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You're right, exactly.
- [Mark] You can say drug
addiction is the issue,
but I really think mental health
is the real issue behind that.
- [Garrett] True.
- [Mark] And then behind that-
- [Garrett] Self-medicating along with it.
- [Mark] The lack of love and childhood
is the core of it all I think.
- [Garrett] Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] 'Cause you can have two parents
in your life and you
can say they loved you
but you can still grow up to be an adult
And not feel like you were ever loved.
- [Garrett] Totally.
- [Mark] I think that's the
most common story I hear.
- [Garrett] Yeah.
- [Mark] Whether the people
understand it themselves or not.
- [Garrett] Right. I think you're right.
Common denominator, you know.
- [Mark] But people would
just say homelessness
and drug addiction is the problem.
Don't really understand it.
- [Garrett] Right.
- [Mark] So do you have people
on the street here that you trust?
- [Garrett] There's a, I
got a very very small circle
and you know, they're not
really on the street though,
like I am. Just local
dealers and stuff like that,
that's got their stuff together, but yeah.
- [Mark] And what kind of
dreams did you have as a kid
of doing as a job? What things did you
wanna do with your life?
- [Garrett] I grew up
surfing and I used to be
in the NSSA as a junior.
But right now, I don't know if you've
ever heard of Mavericks?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Garrett] I should be
surfing right there, right now.
- [Mark] It's the time of year for it.
- [Garrett] Yeah. It's
yeah, I've been missing it
and seeing my buddies and stuff, you know
send me a, show me back on
YouTube what I'm missing
and I'm like, Oh my God.
- [Mark] And you surf
those big, giant waves?
- You know I haven't been
to quite those giant waves,
but you know, ocean beach training ground,
a good place for them.
But I was well on my way there.
I hope to get back there soon.
Get back in shape.
- [Mark] Is there also like
a self-destruction streak
that runs in these guys
that surf those giant waves?
'Cause that's threatening your
life every time you do it.
- For sure. It's certainly
a little healthier though.
I mean-
- [Mark] Yeah, no it's (laughing)
it's probably a healthier form of-
- Healthier form definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] I understand challenging
yourself, but that seems
like, a lot of those
guys end up dying, right?
- Some of them-
- [Mark] A lot. Well,
I shouldn't say a lot,
but it's happened?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It also keeps
you in incredible shape.
- Totally. Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's
probably a very healthy way
to challenge yourself-
- Yeah, it's a lot healthier outlook.
- [Mark] As long as you
don't end up under water,
for too long.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Excellent.
So where, what do you see your chances
are of getting outta here, I mean?
- You know, pretty good.
I will say that I've
done it before, you know,
and this has gone on far
too long, I'll admit it.
It's going on a year now.
It's supposed to be maybe
two, three month thing
and you just keep saying next month
next month, next month, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's the drugs.
- [Mark] Just don't let yourself
become a 60 year old man
still living on the street,
you do see a lot of them.
- Yeah, yeah. Like I said,
it's even embarrassing for me
to even be telling you
this stuff, you know.
I'm much better than this, you know.
- [Mark] I can totally see you cleaning
up and getting your,
getting your life straight.
- Yeah, thank you. Yeah,
I'm much better than this.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned from all this?
- There's quite a few, you know,
whether it's through any kind of community
or any kind of like
support you have, you know,
like use that support
really. Don't neglect it or-
- [Mark] Take advantage of it.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Well, I see a lot
of people that ask for help.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then when
they get offered the help-
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They can't accept it.
- Right. That's true.
- [Mark] And they flake
out and they disappear
and all of a sudden
you're like, here it is-
- Yeah.
- [Mark] On a silver platter.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] Can't accept it.
- Can't accept it, totally. I see that.
I see that left and right.
I can't tell you how
many times I see that.
- [Mark] That self-sabotage
thing kicks in.
- Yeah, big time.
- [Mark] The thing that you
dream about and say you want.
- Is right here, but you just can't do it.
- [Mark] You run away from it.
- Right. Totally. I'm
definitely guilty of that.
- [Mark] I think everybody down here is.
- [Garrett] Yeah.
- [Mark] I think everybody
in the world is guilty of it.
One way or another.
- [Garrett] True that.
- [Mark] We're our own worst enemies.
- [Garrett] Yes, we are.
Everywhere we go, there we are.
(Mark and Garrett laughing)
- [Mark] All right.
Garret, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Yeah, I appreciate it.
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck, man.
- Yeah, yep. Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.